our romantic comedy is driven by plot or
character as a genre that has three
parts the plots just there you know you
get together you get apart and then you
get back together so I don't think it's
so much plot that drives it as it is
character that's where we find our
interest is in the people and how
diverse are they and how opposite are
they or where are their similarities
what is it that took them apart and how
will they possibly get back together and
who's helping them do that and who's
against them doing that so it's more
about character I think in a romantic
comedy because it is a genre and it has
its tropes and it has its steps and if
those aren't happening then you don't
have a romantic comedy
so character is I think the most
important thing and that's what you
should be focusing on let's talk about
the character archetypes because you
have as I was saying earlier sort of the
hero worshiper you had the sort of the
type-a ambitious that doesn't have time
for relationship you might have sort of
the hot girl that no guys sort of good
enough for or similar with the guy and
then you have sort of the shot you know
what are some of the archetypes that we
typically see in romantic comedies
either as a friend or as the protagonist
some of the typical archetypes and in
the book I did have on there's a whole
section in each movie about the lover
types and indeed a lot of what you just
mentioned there's the cynical person now
that's always a real good one somebody
who's been burned and disappointed in
love so the cynic is a wonderful
archetype and I like that definition
that a cynic is just a wounded romantic
so seeing that character change and go
through a character arc can be very
satisfying to us also the person who
doesn't even realize they need love the
clueless no it's different from being a
cynic but the clueless person is just oh
no everything's fine okay maybe I'm in a
loveless relationship but you know it's
convenient it works so they need to be
waked up so they're the archetype of the
person who needs to be awakened
that just kind of what Wow oh and then
you've got another good one is the bossy
person who's always right and always in
charge or always wants to be anyway
and then the person who and I think this
is so well done and down with love where
you've got Ewan McGregor is the the type
a confident always in charge you know
and he's a he's running the show and all
of course all the women love him he's
got you know many many many many
girlfriends and then you have Renee
Zellweger who is the formerly mousy
secretary who I love this and you're
writers I think we'll all just roll
their eyes she says well you weren't
paying any attention to me and so I
decided I was just gonna go off and I
was gonna write a book and so I did and
then it became a best-seller
international and then I said and I went
to see it with uh some writers and we
all went I was that have I supposed to
work right
you just write something and it becomes
an instant international bestseller okay
so she was the person who was waking up
now she was waking herself up but
bringing the two of them together made a
really dynamic energy exchange in that
film down with love so the the various
archetypes you can go from the the
disappointed in love to the still
grieving in must love dogs Christopher
Plummer has a wonderful line he's father
who's a widow
and he says no I know I've had the love
of my life and they'll never ever be
anyone to take her place but I'm just
out there tap dancing as fast as I can
having some fun and just hoping I won't
notice all the time what I've lost and
it's very sad but it's also very hopeful
so many many character types
and play a part in a romantic comedy and
by choosing different types than what
you would think you can make a much more
interesting story
you